since the maximize recycling scheme
began in July 2008 there are certain
items which have never been allowed in
the recyclables and compostable bins the
council collects thousands of tons of
materials each year for a recycling and
occasionally the most from the
collection vehicles contain materials
that are in the incorrect bin known as
contamination contamination makes the
recycling process more time-consuming
costly and inefficient and could also
lead to the whole lower load being taken
to landfill recently we have seen
contamination rates rise and in order to
address this if your bin is contaminated
it we stickered and left uncollected
contamination in the recyclables bin
includes black sacks or bin liners
textiles pieces of plastic wrappings
such as cling film and bubble wrap
nappies other non recyclable waste
including food and household electrical
items such as kettles oils and toasters
the council will collect all carrier
bags that are placed in the recyclables
bin but please put them in loose we
would also ask that you ensure all other
recyclables are rinsed and clean and
placed loose into a bin and if you are
unsure of which item goes into which bin
please check the 80 set of materials at
WWE govt UK /recycling a2z or call
customer services on 0170 2318 one
double one and one of the questions the
council's recycling team are asked most
while there are out and about in the
district is how residents can get more
waste into bins here's some tips from
the team on how you can make the most
out of your recycling bins placing items
into the bins additional capacity
especially in the recyclables bin can be
created by making sure that items are
squashed where possible stacking items
into one another for example plastic
food trays and placing large pieces of
flattened cardboard by the sides of the
bins
home compositing if you have a garden
with space for compost bin then this is
a useful way to not only divert some of
the food and garden waste away from your
compostable has been but also to provide
you with some free compost for your
garden reducing the amount of food you
throw away the love food hate waste
campaign provides lots of information on
reducing the amount of food you buy and
you can find out more at WWF food hate
waste calm bulky waste and electrical
items items of furniture plastic toys
Lionel and carpet tiles can all be
collected via the bulky waste collection
scheme so there is no need for items
such as these to be placed into the
non-recyclables bin small electrical
items such as kettles and toasters can't
be placed into any of the bins as they
are classed as hazardous waste and
should be disposed of at the household
waste site in Castle Road braley the
2011 love where you live campaign is
well underway a processing you can show
your community spirit this autumn by
organizing your own love where you live
events the initiative is intended to act
as a focal point for volunteers across
the county to arrange their own local
cleanup event or any other activity that
brings together and celebrates the local
community the new website www good for
essex org /a love where you live is now
live where you can register your own
events everyone who does this will
receive a free support pack love where
you live activities can be local cleanup
events or anything that benefits the
community these could include picking up
litter removing graffiti weed clearance
planting flowers a fete jumble sale or
craft fair helping elderly residents
lead walks or cycle rides charity
fashion show or coffee morning love
where you live activities will run
throughout 2011 so there's plenty of
time to get involved and organize your
own events as well as visiting WWJ
for Essex org forward slash love where
you live you can receive the latest
updates by following at Essex underscore
love and a score live on Twitter or
becoming a fan of facebook if you wish
to hold a love where you live activity
in a public area you are advised to
contact your local authority first
NHS southeast ethics is urging people to
choose well to ensure they receive the
right treatment and help the NHS to
manage its resources if you're feeling
unwell there are a range of NHS services
available and these are self-care this
is the best choice to treat very minor
injuries a range of common illnesses and
complaints such as coughs colds sore
throats and upset stomachs and apes and
pains can be treated with the world
stocked medicine cabinet and plenty of
rest self care essentials include
paracetamol anti-diarrheal medicines
rehydration mixes indigestion remedies
and a thermometer or have a look at the
NHS Choices dedicated website and at W
NHS UK where you can find up-to-date and
expert advice on a range of illnesses
and complaints as well as finding your
nearest NHS services such as dps
dentists and pharmacists NHS direct on
0845 4647 provides a confidential
telephone service 24 hours a day giving
advice and guidance on health issues
your local pharmacy can provide
confidential expert advice and treatment
for a range of common illnesses and
complaints without having to wait for DP
appointment if you do have an illness or
injury that won't go away make an
appointment with your GP they provide a
range of services by appointment and
when absolutely essential can make home
visits walk-in centres offer convenient
access to a range of treatments for
minor illnesses and injuries your
nearest walk-in centre here is the loops
health center at pentile Avenue
southend-on-sea SS 24 b d it's open
every monday to saturday from eight a.m.
to 8pm including bank holiday
and you can telephone them on zero one
seven zero to 60 1505 and finally any
departments and the 999 ambulances
should only be used in a critical or
life-threatening situation darling 999
and stating an emergency situation will
result in a response vehicle being sent
to your location your nearest ane
department is at Southend hospital on
pretty well chase westcliff-on-sea Essex
SS 00 are Y and their telephone number
is 0 1 702 for 355 double five
a guide with up-to-date information
about local health care services is
available on the NHS south east essex
website at WWE NHS UK the e booklet
entitled your guide to local health
services 2010-11 published by NHS south
east essex contains lots of useful
contact numbers including information
about local NHS dentists GP practices
pharmacies and opticians a variety of
other useful telephone numbers for local
health services and help lines are also
featured in the guide the guide can be
downloaded and printed at local
libraries who do not have internet
internet access at home information
about how NHS south east essex spends
its budget is included you can also find
out more about how you can have your say
when it comes to local health care
services by sharing feedback and being
more involved in the decision-making
process the chairman of NHS south east
essex katherine kurt said there are so
many local health services available
across southeast essex and by having all
the information in one place not only
can people get quick access to their GP
or dentists firm number they can also
find out more about a wealth of other
local services that might be of interest
to them and here's how you can get your
copy of the guide to health services
online you log on to www seu NHS UK on
the front page go to click here to
download your guide 2010-11 once you've
clicked the guide should automatically
appear and as we've said before if you
don't have access to the internet go to
your local library and they can download
a copy for you
the initiative shown by two hotly
teenagers who went to the aid of an
elderly lady in distress has been
recognized by the police and Rochford
district communities 50 partnerships
known as CSP greens would academy
students amy castleton and megan
anderson both 16 have each been
presented with the letter of
commendation from district commander in
chief inspector Glen Wesley and 15 pound
iTunes vouchers by the CSP the girls
were approached by the elderly lady in
white hart lane hockley the woman
confused and disorientated after
mistakenly alighting from a bus had lost
her bag containing her bus passed a
mobile phone and could not remember
where she lived she asked us where the
community hall was but neither of us
knew what she meant so we tried to
direct her to a nearby church but she
didn't really understand explained Amy
and Megan after several attempts to find
someone to help or who might know or
recognize the woman the girls took her
to hockley library and the police were
called police Community Support Officer
John Dennis said the girls showed great
presence of mind in not abandoning the
lady but getting her to a place of
safety fortunately she was later able to
recall the name of the care home which
allowed us to pinpoint its location and
have someone collector
rochford District Council Essex Police
and the CPS have joined forces in a new
initiative to tackle anti-social
behavior and nuisance in hockley working
together the partners have secured a
dispersal order for large areas of the
town giving police proactive powers to
defuse potential nuisance behavior
officers can disperse groups of two or
more people congregating in designated
dispersal areas including Maryland's
Nature Reserve and woods plumber amount
and the grounds of bets would community
center anyone refusing to leave when
asked by the officers or who returns
within 24 hours commits an offense and
can be arrested the order also gives
police the power to take children under
16 years old back home if stopped in a
designated area after 9pm and not
accompanied by a responsible adult in
the month following the introduction of
the order on monday the eleventh of july
police used their powers to remove 66
people there were 15 fewer incidents as
antisocial behavior in the designated
area over this period than the same time
last year
businesses and organizations across the
district are being asked to join the
council's efforts to stop domestic
violence and potentially save a life
they're being asked to support j9 a
campaign to make information about
domestic abuse more accessible by
displaying leaflets in their premises
training one or more employees in
awareness of domestic abuse and by
allowing victims the use of a phone to
get help if they need it virgin active
fitness centers local libraries
children's centers and a number of
schools have already signed up to the
campaign if you run a business or
organization in the Rockford district
and wish to take part in the scheme then
please contact Rockford District
Council's domestic abuse reduction
officer Tracy Schneider on 0 1 702 546
366
a reminder to listeners played by
unsolicited marketing and sales calls
help is at hand in the shape of the
telephone preference service known as
the TPS the TPS maintains the central
opt-out register of people who do not
wish to receive uninvited marketing
approaches companies who knowingly call
numbers registered with the TPS break
the law the service is free and once the
number has been registered it becomes
effective in 28 days so to register call
the TPS registration line on 0845 0700
707 alternatively go to the TPS website
on ww TPS online or guk please make sure
you use this address there have been
instances of people using search engines
to locate the site only to inadvertently
connect to commercial companies who are
charged for their services